il ya un énorme ce courrier ouais
ben arfa tous
les gars de son mari au sénégal est la
cérémonie traditionnelle exactement et
d'ailleurs vous appelez plus gilles il
faut pas que je le dise vous pouvez dire
si vous voulez mais j'ai un oui j'ai un
mot de prénom après l'intense souleymane
mais là bas on m'appelle souleymane est
[Rires]
maintenant il faut toujours la peur
si souleymane heures de retard c'est
très beau sous les drapeaux il
est reconnu en france
jeudi ce mariage s'est marié au dernier
regarde
évidemment oui c'est pas marié quoi moi
même vous serez le 1er juin tenir
compagnie depuis toutes ces années sans
vous on ne seraient pas mariés devraient
bien sûr et bien faire là bas c'est
grâce à vous de faire la bague non